a research project involved talking with
a number of business leaders and showing
them some of the scenarios developed by
the World Bank for the long-term future
and asking them what they thought it
meant for business leaders and I'm in
the middle of finishing with with some
colleagues a book that we hope will be a
fantastic answer to your question but
basically what we can see is that the
way things are playing out is very
uncomfortable the future could involve
substantial breakdowns so that the
people who were involved in our research
were very concerned about capital
markets long before the crisis they saw
the volatility they saw the in the
extent to which the capital markets were
drifting away from their function of
serving industrial markets and were
simply trading systems and they were
very concerned about its implication
they see well when you look at any set
of forecasts what you see is growing
inequality of income within countries
and then across countries really bad so
that even though China and India by say
2050 or 2040 are expected to have
together as much as say forty percent of
the world's GDP
the people in those countries will still
have incomes that are like a third of
those in developed nations and an
average and the averages are a problem
because even if you look at those
nations what you see are the poor are
coming up but that we're getting
staggering I figure china now has
somebody said 62 billionaire something
like well that kind of inequality is
very rough in an age where television
makes everything visible to everyone and
it's very soon when I say everyone on
their cell phones so inequality then
leads to migration that can be highly
destabilizing and so we see for example
in Europe populations that's shrinking
because of age Western Europe and what
are the voters want the voters want more
benefits they want lower taxes they want
show it shorter working weeks and they
want no immigration so what we're
looking is we're moving towards a
something that's going to break down and
so if we if what is the role of business
leaders but the role of business leaders
is to as a community globally to
recognize these problems and to start
making a difference and interestingly
there are companies that are doing just
that a a few are based in the United
States more outside
well I think if you look at china
mobile's getting most of its growth
these days by bringing cell phones too I
think it's essentially a million
villages they're getting down to the
village level they built a distribution
system that's amazing with those cell
phones they can now provide market
information to what are essentially
farmers they're going to if probably if
the government will let them they'll
provide banking for that so you it's a
businessman solution if these people are
poor bring them into the market system
don't give them you know and we're
seeing if people don't have homes find a
way to help them build homes that's
what's MX is doing and figure out how to
distribute to that level and finance it
and then if you look at something like
IBM IBM has put the headquarters of its
market facing activities for emerging
markets in Shanghai not a normal and
they're working to provide the
information systems so that those
companies that are trying to do that can
do it that's where the future of the
market is do you want to essentially the
business question version of that
nightmare I was describing is do you
want to spend your life fighting for the
one-third of the market that's well
developed and in which every company in
the world is present and fighting or do
you want to be a leader developing the
two-thirds of the world's market that
has no competition so that's taking that
big problem that I described and saying
well wait a minute that's a huge
opportunity and that I think is what
what's before us we either develop that
opportunity or face some very very
uncomfortable problems